we have a voicemail number which is 2192
David P You know despite all of my
criticisms of Joe Rogan
here's someone who calls in and says I'm
not willing to criticize Joe Rogan
hey David I think like Rogan I know uh
you know
you hesitate to talk badly about him no
I don't you might have me confused with
someone else I know that there are lots
of people who won't criticize Rogan
but I criticized Rogan all the time in
fact I sort of suspect he probably would
never have me back on as a result of my
criticisms you know to an extent you'll
say things but you still kind of go easy
on them but he's gone man he is
completely gone off the deep end
you see it every single episode I can't
even watch anymore I can't even listen
anymore I agree that he's gone fully
into right wing propaganda but um
you know he's telling people straight up
vote Republicans everything the
Democrats are bad blah blah blah it's
just it's a propaganda Network it's
it's easy soon enough he'll be far right
wing commentator he's already on his way
there yeah listen uh I I criticized
Rogan all the time
um I don't know what you're talking
about the criticisms are not mealy mouth
the criticisms are clear and they're
direct so I I'm just not sure what
you're talking about we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money but
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad we're going to talk
about a Texas school board rejecting In
God We Trust signs in Arabic oh boy here
we go again U.S life expectancy dropped
in 2021 for the second consecutive year
and Sean Hannity Tucker Carlson and Lou
Dobbs are going to be deposed in the
Dominion voting systems lawsuit against
Fox News it is delightful folks it is
delightful all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com and you can use the
coupon code big voting22 to secure a
lifetime discount on your membership